[Musik]
hat sie bekommen meine damen und herren
bei einer neuen ausgabe von verrat es
ist mittwochabend und ich verspreche
ihnen fünf lebendige und sehr
leidenschaftliche den bakken meine
großartigen gäste heute abend sind der
publizist henryk broder der btv scharf
und bild chefredakteur claus strunz
tübingens oberbürgermeister boris palmer
und die cdu bundestagsabgeordneten otto
schily klein und falls sie für nach acht
heute abend das erste mal eingeschaltet
haben sollten jeder von uns hat eine
these mitgebracht die im bewegt erfreut
schockiert oder über die man einfach mal
debattieren will und ich habe mich heute
mal nicht geärgert es wird sie
verwundern mich selbst auch aber ich
habe mich gefreut und zwar über den
niederländischen bundes coach louis van
gaal als er gestern beim spiel gegen das
dfb team fast beiläufig erklärte es sei
immer noch positiv sei begann die
anwesenden deutschen journalisten eifrig
zu tun wie kann das denn sein was macht
ihr hier doch für mich hat van gaal
alles richtig gemacht lassen sie es mich
ihnen erklären seien bz es ist zwar
positiv aber sein arzt hätten gesagt
dass es nur reste erscheinung das sind
die schnelltests von kanal waren alle
negativ
ergo der mann ist gesund und er hat sich
völlig regelkonform verhalten in den
niederlanden gilt darüber hinaus dass
einer krone erkrankter nach fünf tagen
aus der quarantäne darf wenn er keine
symptome mehr ausfalls und wie schön war
von heizung haben mit unserem thomas
müller wie schön ist es endlich wieder
menschen zu sehen gesunde menschen die
nicht mit angst einander begegnen
sondern mit freude anstatt also dass wir
verurteilen und darüber tuscheln warum
er jetzt mit einem noch positiven corona
bz ist an diesem spiel teilnimmt finde
ich wir sollten uns im vorbild nehmen
gesunde menschen müssen raus ins leben
wie sehen sie das
ehrlich gesagt ist das zurzeit nicht
meine allergrößte sorge erstens habe ich
nichts übrig im fußball
zweitens fallen in meinem alter also ich
finde er sollte sich schonen und
übrigens mir ist jeder münchen party
stehen quarantäne ist mit oder ohne
symptome das erhöht die zahl der
verfügbaren parkplätze
[Gelächter]
es war so diplomatisch anfang ja bruder
ich weiß gar nicht was ich darauf
antworte ich erweitere die runde einfach
weil ich schätze dass boris palmer der
uns ja live aus typischen zu gescheit
ist mir wieder sprechen wird und
diskussion belebt ja immer die
unterhaltung in der fall war
da täuschen sie sich ich finde in der
tat dass wir dahin kommen müssen dass
menschen die krank sind zu hause bleiben
und menschen die gesund sind wieder am
leben teilnehmen können die pandemie ist
zwar nicht aber wir können auch nicht
ewig so weiter machen dass wir bei jedem
pc hat es die leute aus dem verkehr
frau doktor klein ich freue mich zwar so
viel zuspruch aber wie ist ihre meinung
ich bin mir da tatsächlich nicht so
sicher also ich teile die euphorie nicht
denn wenn wir eins wissen über corona
ist dass wir im grunde genommen immer
noch nicht so viel wissen und wir wissen
einfach nicht kommt es zu mutationen
vielleicht nochmal wie entwickelt sich
die pandemie insofern bin ich da eher
ein bisschen vorsichtiger und wäre
tatsächlich dafür dass wir bei pcr test
positiv ergebnissen doch noch mal ein
bisschen abstand halten und das
schrittweise angehen
ich bin auch jetzt haben wir mal eher
skeptisch und und würde jetzt louis van
gaal nicht unbedingt zu jubeln für die
für das was hat er gemacht hat alles was
gesagt wird stimmt wir müssen zur
normalität zurück aber bei einem mann
der so in der öffentlichkeit steht ist
es ja auch ein symbol also er sagt damit
ich habe den positiven test aber kümmere
mich halt nicht richtig darum sondern
ich bin gesund und ich kann jetzt machen
was ich will ich fürchte dass das bei
menschen die nicht so unter
gesundheitlicher kontrolle sind wie
leistungssportler und deren trainer wo
man auf die expertise des arztes quasi
in jeder minute zurückgreifen kann dass
manche leute daraus vielleicht den
falschen schluss ziehen und sagen jetzt
ist wieder alles mit jedem möglich und
wo ich huste und spucke und habe auch
schon ein bisschen fieber aber ich kann
jetzt trotzdem mit dem busfahrer umarmen
das wäre dann ein fatales signal
deswegen ist es so ich habe heute auch
schon ganzen tag überlegt wie ich das
finden soll einerseits sehne ich mich
danach das genau die szenen wieder die
normalität werden andererseits habe ich
schon so leichtes stück
vor dem hintergrund der vorbildfunktion
hättest du denn lust wenn du symptomfrei
werft zehn tage quarantäne zu gehen ich
glaube dass das die eigentliche
mitgelieferte laser symptomfrei her die
eigentliche lieferte botschaft glaube
ich kann mir von boris palmer die
quarantäne regeln machen den unterschied
also wir müssen eigentlich dazu kommen
quarantäne für symptomlose menschen
selbst bei positiven test abzuschaffen
andere länder haben das geschafft aber
symptomlose menschen können immer noch
andere anstalt ja mir ist das klar aber
das würde ich sagen ist dass das ein
lebensrisiko das restrisiko es ist ein
lebensrisiko ein restrisiko restrisiko
ist gemein weil das stammt von
atommeilern und so
richtig möglich also viel angesagt wenn
sie die luft fliegen aber ich glaube
dass das wir uns hier das zeige nicht
der maßstab also so lange es noch der
atommeiler nächste leichtes quarantäne
regeln gibt
kommen wir nicht zurück in die freiheit
aber es gibt so viele sachen die in
dieser situation von com albums sind
wissen sie ich bin neulich versehentlich
in einem flugzeug geflogen ich saß so da
was natürlich bei meiner größe kein
großes problem ist aber auch erwachsene
menschen sassen zutaten sie würden
leiden und die leute stiften um
schriften und hatten alle masken an und
ich hätte gerne die maske abgenommen und
dann beim aufsteigen hieß es achten sie
bitte auf den abstand ja das war der
moment wo ich mich fragte die wollen
einen falschen oder alle vieles vieles
wird immer unverständlich und wissen sie
bei den beiden flüchten
ist die haben irgendwie auch nicht auf
den abstand geachtet als sie in china's
laufen bahnsteig standen also was soll
es dann und wenn es in berlin eine demo
gibt dann fängt der einsatz der polizei
davon ab für oder gegen wen die demo ist
und die einen dürfen masken tragen die
anderen können und die anderen können
machen was sie wollen also ist sehr viel
taktik dabei um nicht zu sagen
politische ranschmeißen also wenn ein
ergebnis dieser phase sein sollte dass
man beliebig mit unterschiedlicher lms
dann in einem rechtsstaat dann ein
regionalleiter gekommen nein dann haben
wir dann haben wir wirklich longo wird
dann ist das wirklich longkou wird keine
haben wir lankowitz der bruder und herr
strunz war eigentlich festgestellt haben
nein also ich finde ja da sind wir die
kirche im dorf lassen klar sind viele
regeln nicht bis ins letzte logisch war
schon gefragt jetzt muss ich zwei
stunden die maske tragen der
veranstaltung mit abstand aber danach
ist es auch dass alle die maske
ausziehen immer gemeinsam zum buffet
geht und dann dort zusammen steht was
hat ist angebracht wenn der
veranstaltung die maske da gebe ich ihn
schon recht das ist nicht bis zu ende
alles logisch und strich gehen aber das
ganze ist halt auch unvollkommen und
sicherlich nicht widerspruchsfrei wir
irgendwie versuchen verhalten zu
reglementieren
das kann der staat nur sowieso nur ganz
bedingt da muss man sich damit abfinden
dass ist da halt auch zu wenn ich ein
bisschen albern etwas widersprüchlich in
sachen kommt es bedeute nicht dass da
absicht dahintersteckt sein dass keiner
dieser vorschläge befunden hat natürlich
ist es absicht die frage wie es nun wie
sie absicht definieren es ist nicht die
absicht die leute zu etwas zu zwingen
aber sie sich so aus die absicht ein
klima zu schaffen das von angst regiert
wird und was hat auch prima funktioniert
und inzwischen sehe ich nicht nur bei
rtl aber vor allem dort verzweifelt der
menschen die sagen sie möchten die maske
anbehalten sie fühlen sich dann
irgendwie besser es gibt inzwischen
wunderbare artikel in völliger toms dass
die maske zur schönheit der erscheinung
bei trinkt weil man nun die einzige
sichere also es gibt jetzt schon diese
tests ist wenn ihr meine maske trägt
mann der sich selbst als sicherer und
den anderen als empathischer ja ja ja
was gleich zwei illusion und auf einmal
vielleicht daran weil man sich gesund
fühlt was ich ja ganz ganz spannend fand
damit lassen wenn die leute
den schluss ziehen sie wollen weiter
maske tragen sollen sie halt weiter
maske tragen so lang nicht daraus folgt
dass ich auch gerne tragen muss also das
fände ich sozusagen also geeignet um
sich darüber lustig zu machen wenn man
anderer meinung ist aber jetzt als jeder
nach seiner fasson eigentlich ein
schritt in die richtige richtung gerade
bei der maske naja wer sich damit
sicherer fühlt so soll es doch maria
stört niemand an da sie möchten auch
nicht aus wenn wir angehörige von fkk
clubs bei edeka laden ein aber die haben
mir weniger an die mit der maske nein
ich finde wenn es regen wenn uns regeln
gibt sollten regeln schon verbindlich
sein für alle schnell einig meinte der
bewerber und verstand da bin ich nicht
hab sie missverstanden er sei
missverstanden das heißt ich habe ich
einverstanden
ich glaub ja also die meine überlegung
setzte an wenn es keine masken pflicht
mehr gibt muss ist ja trotzdem jemanden
freigestellt sein eine zu tragen ja es
gibt ja auch keine hut pflicht und
trotzdem sehe ich manchmal leute mit
hüten umlauf das ist ein sehr gutes bild
ab morgen ist es von mir ich denke was
das beispiel einfach zeigt dass das eine
ganz große sehnsucht einfach vorhanden
ist nach normalität auch ein stück weit
nach mehr herzlichkeit ein bisschen mehr
miteinander und das ist auch sehr
verständlich nach zwei jahren pandemie
dennoch muss ich das zurückweisen dass
sie gesagt haben dass wir ein klima der
angst schaffen wollen das ist mitnichten
so es geht natürlich um den schutz der
bevölkerung und wir haben es hier
einfach mit einer pandemie zu tun immer
noch auch und nicht mit einer grippe das
ist kein schutz der bevölkerung hält das
ehepaar sein eigenheim fellas 300 meter
zum zigarettenautomaten geht und wieder
zurück und daraufhin jeweils 500 euro
strafe zahlen dahinter steckt nicht die
idee des schutzes der bevölkerung
das ist oftmals auch widersprüchlich ist
gebe ich zu das ist so auch wenn ich
jetzt selber nicht dafür verantwortlich
bin für diese regelung dennoch ist die
politische vorstellung rheinau und aber
dennoch die politik muss natürlich
gucken und flexibel auf die neue
situation reagieren und
haben und so kommt der politik auch eine
versuchsanordnung ganz zu passen nicht
wahr wenn mit hoch schrauben leute von
stränden verjagt wird wissen sie oder
wenn ein 17-jähriger quer durch ein
hamburger park von einem streifenwagen
gejagt wird dann glaube ich nicht dass
es wirklich zeichen der fürsorge sind
das ist eine versuchsanordnung
sicherheit nicht bösartig nicht meins
jahr alle gut meine sagen sie mir
jemanden ist nicht gut meint nicht
vielleicht putin damals wahrscheinlich
nicht gut aber ansonsten hat es schon
großen charakter von einen großen zug
von social engineering gehabt und es gab
ganz viele situationen wo man wirklich
ausprobieren konnte wie weit man leute
durch die vermittlungs- und angst
bringen kann das hat funktioniert also
dass auch das weise ich zurück dass wir
hier social engineering betreiben in der
politik das ist einfach nicht der fall
sie ist die grundlage der politik der ok
also wir versuchen einfach auf die
situation zu reagieren um die
bevölkerung bestmöglich zu schützen und
da geht es insbesondere auch um die
wohlhabenden gruppen um die
risikogruppen um die ältere generation
haben sie mich damals
noch schwere verläufe hat und deswegen
es geht um den schutz da bleibe ich
dabei ja ich habe meine solidarische
kombination hinter mir das schöne ist ja
man sollte sich auch streiten wir wollen
ja genau das ist ja ein regen
produktiven streit ist wegen ich glaube
da kommen jetzt frau klein und herr
bruder nicht mehr zu sagen bei dem thema
aber vielleicht bei dem nächsten das
nämlich claus strunz schon den ganzen
tag beschäftigt oder schon länger als
nur heute beschäftigt und ich will auch
gar nicht so viel vorweg nehmen ja viel
länger ist beschäftige mich seit einigen
tagen da bin ich irgendwie rein geraten
in eine szene in die man nicht so oft in
seinem leben gerät und auch nicht
geraten will da können wir sie noch
einmal sehen oliver pocher kriegt einen
schlag ins gesicht und ich sitze neben
dran eine zweite sitzt christoph daum
und dann saß ich da und wenn ich mir die
szene so angucke dann frage ich mich bis
heute warum klaus bist du eigentlich
nicht dazwischen gesprungen warum bist
du das sitzengeblieben okay ich sage ein
bisschen was und ich kann hinterher auch
analysieren da spätestens war diese sind
sie da ich sitze da der der dass der
daumen und dahinten der übernächste bin
ich also ein meter fünfzig entfernt mit
abstand aber eher weil eben so zu sagen
keiner massenhafte keiner hat das kann
da waren alle getestet dieses jedenfalls
aber was mich reden was mich wirklich
umtreibt ist dieses blick auf mich
selbst warum ich da nicht eingeschritten
bin und das kann man sich jetzt
schönreden und sagen ja die situation
war dann geklärt oder dafür sind die
ordner zuständig und das stimmt auch
alles für den moment danach aber dieser
moment diesem moment wo der schläger vor
oliver pocher steht oliver pochers
schutzlos da würde ich heute sagen
verstehe ich mich selber nicht warum ich
da nicht dazwischen gegangen bin und das
obwohl ich oft ja zivilcourage von
anderen verlangen und das gibt mir
irgendwie den gedanken mit dass wir in
eine ungewöhnliche situation keiner hat
es erwarte dass gegen wahnsinnig schnell
passiert wenn eine extremsituation
passiert dann reagiert man
offensichtlich anders als einem lieb ist
und deshalb ist es mir ein wirkliches
anliegen oliver pocher einmal zuzurufen
oli sorry dass ich dir nicht geholfen
hat das nächste mal springen wir die
alle zur seite das ist eine spannende
frage jetzt sie würde ich direkt mal
gerne ein herr palmer spielen stichwort
zivilcourage heime hätten sie denn
eingegriffen und verstehen sie warum
herr strom sich jetzt schlecht für das
er es nicht getan hat
wird es weiter das tue ich verstehe ist
dass man sich danach eher fragwürdig was
machen können aber wenn ich diese
videoaufnahmen mir zu sehen dann habe
ich den eindruck das kam so was du nicht
so überraschend dass er quasi die gabel
der vorsehung hätte haben müssen dagegen
irgendwas zu tun das war doch gar nicht
möglich da einzugreifen da kann man denn
wissen dass dieser typ daher kommen zu
den einfach um halte sich ich kann es
gar nicht fassen wir sowas passieren
also bis zu dem bis zu dem schlag stimmt
dass da kann man wirklich nichts machen
dass wir vollkommen überraschend dann
ist auch noch finde ich eine
zehntelsekunde konsterniert sein okay
aber dann gibt es diese merkwürdige
situation nach dem schlag wo ein opfer
das wird oliver pocher nicht gerne über
sich hören aber es war der situation so
ein opfer schutzlos da ist und ein täter
vor ihm steht und da muss man eigentlich
dazwischen gehen übrigens wichtig nicht
meine kritik hat mir selber ist jetzt
nicht dass ich den hätte schlagen sollen
aber schützend dazwischen gehen das ist
doch das was wir uns eigentlich immer
wünschen und ich frage mich echt warum
das ausgesetzt hat vom ende her
betrachtet freue ich mich dass jetzt
nicht was war ein schlimmes passiert ist
oliver pocher klagt zwar wohl über
ohrenschmerzen
aber man konnte auch in der situation
schon sehen dass er jetzt also keinen
großen schaden davon getragen hat in
sicherheit war dass diese fat comedy
heißt wie ich gelernt habe schläger auch
keinen anderen mehr hauen wird also das
war bereinigt aber dieser eine moment
macht mir schon also dem see ich dauernd
vor mir und denkt war auch gehabt hast
du dann geschah das war 100 mal 200 mal
angehalten es gefiel mir besser ja es
ist der moment nicht die beichte
abgelegt habe mich mit wirklich
interessieren so zu sagen ob wir von
anderen immer was verlangen sozusagen
zivilcourage und dann kommt man selber
in so einem moment und sieht ein video
auf dem man das jetzt und irgendwie sagt
was soll das sage ich da glaube ich was
soll das aber könnte es nicht sein dass
sie falls der anstalten gemacht hätte
weiterzumachen dann einige schritt doch
das würde ich mir auch das wäre aber es
gibt ja den schon vorher es gibt im
moment den schutz moment ich würde auch
sagen wenn wenn der sozusagen meiner
frau eine geknallt hätte wäre ich
wahrscheinlich sofort aufgestanden die
beine geplant womit wir bei will smith
werden ja also das hätte so viel quasi
archaische intuition würde ich mir noch
zu trauen ja da ist auch schluss mit
pazifismus und umso mehr wundere ich
mich an der stelle dass das so gar
nichts war ganz merkwürdig glaube das
war schockstarre für mich sieht es aus
wie
ich finde es auch eine mauer also freue
mich dass sie so deuten aber ich finde
es für mich eine mauer entschuldigung ja
wenn das alle leute die nicht helfen
sagen ja dabei irgendwie in schockstarre
da im bus ist irgendwie eine jacke
geklaut worden von zwei typen da war ich
in schockstarre die frau die da
irgendwie blöd angequatscht und
angegriffen wurde von obst da war ich so
in schockstarre also ich das bewegt mich
wirklich also auch in der hinsicht was
man von anderen verlangt also kann man
von anderen verlangen was man selber
nicht eigentlich gut jeder von uns hat
jeder reagiert anders auf so etwas
vielleicht hat auch jeder in so einer
situation an als wären sie denn schon
mal in so einer situation nein aber ich
würde auch nicht herüber hingehen wie
oliver pocher herumsitzt und geboxt
haben soll nein lesen sie das ganze es
ist eigentlich völlig wurscht so aber
wenn sie mich schon fragen
es ist eigentlich nichts passiert das
was sie da gesehen passiert in den
berliner verkehrsbetrieben fast täglich
und nur selten kommt das als fünfteilige
meldung im tagesspiegel an die
öffentlichkeit also
das ist halt der flucht der prominenz
ist oliver pocher erwischt hat aber ich
möchte mich so gerne an eure aufregung
beteiligen habe es wird nicht gelingen
dann hat das auch noch der schläger hat
ist auch noch filmen lassen ja was sonst
so misst dann sehen wir ja das macht man
jetzt so
und so zu sagen das passiert natürlich
verstärkt auf dem schulhof auch yao
hatte das live gestreamt nein das hat
dann nicht so dass sonja dann soll er
sie nicht hat dann war es ein amateur
dann geht es nicht ich mag ihr zugang zu
wichtigen
ja sie ist ja also ich denke sie haben
ja auch ein stück weit selbst zweifel
und fragen sich ja kann man das von
anderen erwarten wenn man das selber
nicht liefert ich denke dass auch
zivilcourage schon ist wenn man
beispielsweise auf der straße sieht wie
einer frau gewalt angetan wird
beispielsweise und man nimmt den hörer
in die hand und ruft die polizei auch
das ist zivilcourage man muss sich nicht
so zu sagen da hinstellen und
zurückbauen ich denke das kann man nicht
von jedem erwarten aber vielleicht auch
ich glaube auch dass ich teile den
eindruck dass es vielleicht wirklich so
ein schockmoment ist einfach mal werden
man ist nicht in diesem kontext man ist
auf einer veranstaltung
und dann passiert irgendwas womit man
wirklich gar nicht gerechnet hat aber
ich bleibe bei ihrem beispiel
eine frau wird das angetan man
beobachtet es ist es ihrer meinung nach
wirklich ausreichend dann zum hörer zu
greifen die polizei anzurufen die dann
wenn es schnell geht in drei oder fünf
minuten da ist da kann ja weiß was
passiert sein also muss nicht doch auch
ein gestus sein sich selber einzubringen
und vielleicht sogar in gefahr zu
begeben um einem anderen zu helfen
stunde per stunden- sie sind wirklich
ein idealist und
das war sie gerade bescheiden
es wurde zeit eine einer muss den anfang
mehr nein das war so etwas schreiben ist
ungefähr zustand einen normalen
gesellschaft einen 20er 30er jahren aber
inzwischen sind wir gründlich pazifik
ziert worden inzwischen gilt ja
selbstverteidigung sogar als eine
aggressive haltung und was mich im
negativen sinn da wahnsinnig beeindruckt
hat weil dieser lustigen silvester
nachdem köln 20.15 glaube ich ich habe
lange fast alles darüber gelesen wenn
mich einer frage beschäftigt als die
frauen belästigt angeklagt und befindet
wurden die waren da allein unterwegs ja
da waren kein männer dabei keine freunde
keine verwandten keine eltern
geschwister von männern war in der
ganzen berichterstattung wissen sie
nicht aufgefallen nicht die rede das
heißt in einer gesellschaft die so
gründlich pazifik ziert wurde das selbst
in einer solchen situation die man sich
traut zuzuschlagen als ich das gesehen
habe dachte ich ja ich hätte vielleicht
stadt großes latinum einen box kurs
machen sollen wenn ich jemals noch die
gelegenheit dazu haben aber die nicht
fürs boxen
ich finde ihre beschreibung absolut aber
finden sie es und dafür kennt man sie
erfinden sie es gut oder schlecht das
ist diese partie
zertifizierung geschlecht absolut
schlecht absolut schlecht wie erleben
das jetzt sagen mittelmeer werden
vielleicht später darüber reden hier hat
der aggressor einen bonus seiner handelt
und diejenige dass ich verteidigt hat
einmal los weil er die eskalation der
gewalt weiter treibt also einem opfer
wird geraten sich unauffällig zu
benehmen und nicht allzu viel widerstand
auszuüben dann ist es schneller vorbei
und das ist ja auch passiert stellen
sich vor taucher hätte zurückgeschlagen
das war dann schon eine miniserie
geworden ist das wäre damit nach arten
bei rtl laufen ja es würde eine
massenschlägerei gewann das wäre eine
massenschlägerei geworden und ich blieb
dann auch der hatte ehrlich gesagt den
gedanken und nicht den politischen
gedanken den sie äußern dass wir hier
quasi in einer miniatur sehen was in der
ukraine passiert ja mit einem aggressor
und ohne sozusagen das jemand beispringt
es noch nie auf gefragt man nicht viel
phantasie um die analogie noch nie
aufgefallen dass es so ist
ein neues debatten koppel gefunden das
merkt man jetzt schon aber wir wollen
trotzdem nochmal so herr weimar nach
tübingen schalten einmal und die frage
ständig irgendwie sehr spannend den
gedanken sie eingeworfen haben dass man
bisher aber einfach ich sehr spannend
wenn anderen natürlich auch aber den
spannendsten gedanken gefahr nicht daran
wie sehen sie das denn mit der
entmilitarisierung der gesellschaft und
auch mit dem pazifismus der gesellschaft
was der bruder angesprochen hat und
danach mit claus strunz debattiert hat
ca also ich halte das für eine
errungenschaft wenn die gesellschaft die
gewalt mehr und mehr zurück trägt
ratifizierung ist ja nur ein
komplizierter begriff dafür dass man die
dinge nicht mehr mit dem fast recht
regelt sondern sagt das cook bei uns
nicht vor und wenn jemand gewalt ausübt
dann ist es der staat durch seine
polizei sonst aber niemand das halte ich
jetzt noch eine errungenschaft und
findet es gut dass man nicht auch auf
der straße damit rechnen muss dass
irgendwelche leute umhauen und die
anderen dazu kommen und sagen na ja
braucht man die straßenschlacht raus
hätte ich mich nicht zurück aber
trotzdem hat er sich an einer stelle
punkt ist darf nicht aufhören das opfer
schutzlos werden und da muss ich ihnen
leider sagen die erfahrung habe ich
schon öfter gemacht ich bin leider als
oberbürgermeister immer wieder auch
tätlich angegriffen worden und es ist
mir nie jemand der seite gesprungen
auf der straße ja
und ich sie nur also sie haben nie den
schutz erfahren von anderen unternehmen
standen
da war ich immer allein es gab immer
leute dabei stand und erstaunt waren und
geguckt haben aber dass nach einer
eingeschritten wäre zu meinen gunsten es
kam nicht vor
und welche was hinterlässt es bei ihnen
sozusagen
öffnen
fitnesscenter gehen und muskeltraining
damit man sich selber verteidigen kann
oder
das ist ja ich spreche nicht so gelassen
aus aber das ist im grunde schrecklich
es wurde nie bedrohlich dass ich
tatsächlich mal zusammengeschlagen
worden wäre sondern das war immer nur
davor also in physische bedrohung die
stücke waren auch mal einen crosscheck
oder
hinterherlaufen schläge anderen das
jetzt alles geben bis jetzt nicht dazu
gekommen dass ich je tanztag verletzt
worden natürlich hat wahrscheinlich
anders darüber sprechen aber wie gehe
ich damit um mehr als ich sage ihnen
ganz offen ich klamotten aus wenn man
diese gefahr die irgendwie als person
der öffentlichkeit halt latent gesteht
dass man da auf offener straße
angegriffen wird wenn man die nicht
verdrängen können dann kann man
eigentlich nicht mehr im amt nachgehen
und ich will mich davon einfach nicht
beirren lassen
das finde ich schön ab und das schöne
ist ja auch ein innerhalb einer sie
haben sich da auch nie bei gorillas und
hatten besonders in der korona pandemie
immer eigene modelle für tübingen und
jetzt scheint es mir fast so und damit
kommen wir zu ihrer these als hätten sie
jetzt auch ein ganz eigenes modell wie
man eigentlich tübingen und das könnte
man ja wieder ausweiten auf den rest der
republik gas frei machen kann russland
also vielleicht nicht ganz so originell
und eigensinnig wie sich jetzt an
schließen aber ich will mal erklären als
der gedanke ist und was es geht wir
haben ja in tübingen schon lange uns
vorgenommen unabhängig zu werden von öl
kohle und gas gar nicht weil ich putin
dabei gedacht hätte sondern weil wir das
klima schützen wollen unser ziel ist bis
2030 komplett auf fossile energieträger
zu verzichten so hat es der gemeinderat
beschlossen und dabei haben wir uns auch
vorgenommen die stadt nochmal umzugraben
überall fernwärme zu verlegen und diese
scherben werden dann mit erneuerbarer
energie zu erzeugen also wegzukommen von
gas als brennstoff für die
wärmeversorgung unterstadt
mittelfristziel tagen bauen wir zum
beispiel eine große solaranlage die die
wärme ins netz einspeist oder was wir
auch vorhanden dass wir die wir haben ja
in der kläranlage zurückgewinnen also
nicht mehr den neckar beheizen sondern
die abwärme aus der kläranlage aus dem
abwasser rausziehen
und dann wieder zurück speisen in die
fernwärmenetze da kommt man gut voran
aber das dauert natürlich noch ein
bisschen bis man das sieht und jetzt
aktuell denke ich es wäre nötig die
möglichkeiten die heute schon sind sich
vom gas unabhängig zu machen dann bin
ich die industrie abgeschaltet werden
muss oder putin weiter geld von uns
erhält schnell zu nutzen und da gibt es
eine möglichkeit wir haben nämlich für
unser fernwärmenetz redundanz also
doppelte erzeugungs infrastruktur so
können sowohl mit erdgas den strom und
fernwärme erzeugen sie mal was heute als
auch mit strom oder öl heizen wir
könnten also das gas einfach aussetzen
warum machen wir das noch nicht weil es
sehr viel teurer ist das heißt hier wäre
der bund meine ich aufgefordert den
kommunen viele kommunen solche optionen
die entsprechenden mehrkosten zu
ersetzen dann könnten wir ganz schnell
gast ob auch erheblich gut daran
frau doktor kleiner wird ich sie direkt
einmal gerne fragen ist es denn sinnvoll
das schon wieder dann der staat
einspringt wieder der staat eigentlich
auch zahlt wie würden sie das modell
analysieren von der
ja also zunächst mal ist es richtig dass
wir uns unabhängig machen müssen von
fossilen energieträgern ich denke das
ziel teilen wir alle
überfraktionelle auch ein boot deutschen
bundestag nur gleichzeitig müssen wir
eben durchaus schauen wie wir mit dem
steuergeld umgehen denn wir haben jetzt
ja auch gerade über die ampel regierung
ein sehr teures sogenanntes
entlastungspaket wurde eingebracht das
ist aus meiner sicht in der
beruhigungspille auf pump da wird wieder
ordentlich schulden gemacht
und ich bin mir nicht so sicher also für
mich hört sich das alles nicht
durchdacht an ich finde das toll dass
sie in tübingen diese lösungen haben und
die konzepte und ideen und für
deutschland wir sind ja die viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt ich glaube dann
müssten wir da noch mal ein bisschen ein
bisschen ganzheitlicher denkt man noch
mal ein bisschen anders die sache
angehen aber grundsätzlich finde ich das
gut dass sie auf kommunaler ebene da
kreative ideen einbringen
herr bruder wie sieht's denn aus sie
werden es nicht schaffen ja mit der
energiewende mit putins gassen der große
themen und natürlich auch mit den kosten
für die bürger wir werden es nicht
schaffen wir werden es nicht schaffen
wir schaffen es jetzt schon nicht
schauen sie die inflation ist bei 7
prozent angekommen nachdem uns jahrelang
gesagt wo der erstens haben wir keine
wenn wir eine haben ganz wenig und
sollte das mehr wert wird sie sich
zurück entwickeln so das ist da eine
preis den wir zahlen der zweite preis
ist der dass wir nur eine abhängigkeit
durch eine andere tauschen ich weiß
nicht wessen moralisch höherwertig ist
gas aus katar zu beziehen statt aus
russland so und das dritte ist ja dass
wir
wir also ich weiss nicht also dass die
aktuellen wir
kraftwerke in die luft gejagt haben die
intakt waren die vermutlich nicht
umweltschädlich waren sie mussten wissen
sie das hat mich sehr beeindruckt es
genügte nicht die abzuschalten die
mussten auch dem erdboden gleichgemacht
werden da ist etwas krankes dabei wissen
sie dass man mit gewalt verhältnisse
verändern will die nicht verändert
werden können und ich finde das ganz
prima dass das wie man so was macht und
meine wenn thüringen auf island liegen
würde dann hätten sie geo wärme dann
bräuchten sie eigentlich gar nichts da
müssen sie nur paar liter benzin für die
autos importiert alles andere geht an
die mit geo wärme
aber ich glaube nicht dass es in der
stadt wie vor wolfsburg oder irgendeine
andere industriestadt als beispiel
dienen kann aber auf kommunale lokaler
ebene alle achtung sehr gut ich werde
sie trotzdem nicht
warum
nein das ist eine andere geschichte nein
das ist schon okay finde ich ganz prima
ich bin bei jedem grünen froh da etwas
macht was ihn in konflikt mit seiner
partei projekt und das schafft er jedes
mal herr palmer glauben sie das bringt
sie jetzt wieder in den konflikt mit der
partei da sehe ich doch bei dem plan
jetzt nicht und vor allem sie werden
doch jetzt auch oberbürgermeister zur
wahl antreten ohne die grünen
danach sieht es aber nein das halte ich
für ein konfliktthema mit meiner partei
ich würde gern auf den ökonomischen ein
mann noch mal eingehen weil den finde
ich sehr wichtig man muss einfach klar
sehen den uns das erdgas ausgeht weil
putin hahn abdreht oder dass es
irgendwann doch zu sanktionen greift die
den import von peter sie übrigens
richtig finden würde ich kann das nicht
verstehen warum wir diesen krieg jeden
tag mit 200 millionen euro ist
deutschland finanzieren weil wir uns
nicht für diesen gasimport unabhängig
machen können dann dann ist es so immens
viel teurer als die differenz zwischen
dem erdgaspreis für die fernwärme in
tübingen und dem öl oder den strompreis
dass man aus kostengründen das unbedingt
machen müsste das ist so immens teuer
wir den tübingen die industrie nicht
mehr arbeiten kann weil sie kein erdgas
hat wenn der isaf zu machen muss den
stahl beschließen müssen da reden wir
von sich und auf 100 milliarden euro
schaden an der wirtschaft und hier geht
es darum das halt der preis für eine
kilowattstunde wärme dann irgendwie 20
oder 30 prozent steigen müsste und was
ich halt nicht machen kann als
aufsichtsratsvorsitzender stadtwerke
tübingen zu sagen den verlust tragen die
stadtwerke das ist bei uns nicht drin
aber da muss ich doch ein elementares
interesse diese schäden an der
volkswirtschaft zu vermeiden und der
könnte jetzt steht nun die differenz
sitzen und da geht es wirklich um viel
also bei uns ist das ein sechstel des
gasverbrauchs er das sofort ersetzt
werden könnte und viele städte haben
solche netze und solche
erzeugungsanlagen die also sofort
umschalten könnten auch schon anderen
energieträger bei
dass wir alles hören jetzt schon die
vorstufe der gas krise ausgerufen dass
wir nicht so einfach eine möglichkeit
die uns fast nichts kostet und niemand
weh tut dass man die nicht ungenutzt
lassen sollte japan das mich an fast
nichts kostet macht mich gleich sehr
skeptisch das war auch das versprechen
dass die energiewende jeden haushalt im
monat so viel kosten würde wie eine
kugel eis also wenn ich höre etwas
kostet nichts dann spüre ich mir gleich
die taschen zu weil das wird teuer und
er hat sich nicht nur eine partie
fixierung der gesellschaft durchgesetzt
hier ist eigentlich alles verstaatlicht
worden susanne gaschke vor zwei tagen
erfordernden text in der welt gehabt
dass jedes problem mit in deutschland
mit geld zugedeckt wird egal was es ist
und den leuten die wenig verdienen ist
dann ein zuschuss versprochen wurden von
135 euro der wurde dann generös auf 300
euro erhöht und dass es ungefähr der
betrag um den das einkommen von olaf
scholz zunimmt weil sich die
abgeordneten gerade wieder eine erhöhung
ihrer diäten erlaubt haben
ja ja ja
ja vielleicht vielleicht nicht für alle
aber jetzt jetzt möchte ich ihnen meine
ernsthaft die frage stellen weil sie
weiß oder auf ein anderes themenfeld ich
habe keine idee ist es nicht sinnvoll
etwas mehr geld auszugeben für öl und
strom also erwägen die kohle zur
erzeugung von fernwärme und damit die
industrie am laufen zu halten ist es
nicht ökonomisch sehr viel sinnvoller
als das gas jetzt zu verbrennen und
daher die industrie abzuschalten sie
wissen zuerst für die industrie
ausgeschaltet hatten das gaskraftwerk
soll hier nicht auch so eine möglichkeit
nutzen unsere industrie weiter laufen
das ja sie haben vollkommen rechnen ich
bin vollkommen ihrer meinung außerdem
ist es nicht eine ökonomische frage seit
vier wochen finde ich es unmoralisch in
einer beheizten wohnung zu leben wissen
wem wir dieser kuschelige wärme zu
verdanken hat also selbst wenn die
energiekosten und die heizungskosten
steigen würden wäre das schon sehr
bitter ein moralisches gebot der stunde
nachdem in dieser republik die 60 jahre
damit vertan wurden nie wieder zu rufen
und nachdem ein bekannter politiker
wegen auschwitz in die politik gegangen
ist vielleicht könnte auch jetzt wegen
bioko entschuldigung die stadt hat ein
dass wer ist was ja vielleicht könnt ihr
jetzt wegen es aus der spd austreten
nein ich will damit sagen dass auch
moralisches verhalten nicht nur eine
frage des individuellen verhalten ist
sondern es so etwas wie eine kollektive
moral gibt und sich jetzt von putin die
wärme liefern zu lassen um den preis
eines massenmordes ist ziemlich
unmoralisch
sie können mir jetzt ruhig zu das findet
dass wir den schaden ersetzt sind starke
worte ich habe aber noch einen anderen
punkt aufgeschnappt in der debatte den
ich über den tag hinaus und über das
konkrete thema hinaus interessant finde
nämlich die gesamtheitliche lösung die
sie gesagt haben ich glaube deutschland
wenn deutschland zugrunde geht geht es
zugrunde an gesamtheitliche lösungen es
ist doch nichts besseres geben dieses
dass diese sehnsucht dass man eine sache
für alle gleich geregelt es gibt doch
nichts besseres als dass ein
bürgermeister der von seiner stadt mehr
versteht als jeder
andere von außerhalb einen vorschlag
entwickelt und um finanzhilfe bitten
das zu unterstützen als es nicht zu
unterstützen und zu sagen wir arbeiten
an einer gesamtheitlichen lösung und so
weiter die dann irgendwann fertig ist
wenn es viel zu spät ist das sieht man
aus meiner sicht in vielen
politikfeldern mein plädoyer wäre also
denen die ahnung haben nämlich denen vor
ort zuzuhören und wahrscheinlich wäre es
die beste antwort auf diese gaskrise und
dieses gas problem wenn man allen
bürgermeistern einfach sagen würde wir
zahlen eine rechnung die du mit deiner
neuen innovativen lösung für den ort
geschaffen hast und der bund bezahlt es
einfach das wäre kurz schnell hilfe
nicht gesamtheitlich aber am ende dann
noch viel gesamtheitlicher weil alle was
davon hätten das finde ich sehr sehr es
ist finde ich fast programmatisch und
boris palmer hat ja das geschick die
bundespolitik mit punktuellen
vorschlägen die in sich absolut sind
haft sind sozusagen ein bisschen vor
sich herzutreiben und deshalb können
viele das auch nicht leiden weil sie in
diesem gesamtheitlichen festhängen das
waren idee da war sie noch die menge des
punktuellen viel besser als das eine
langdauernde am ende sowieso nicht
funktionierende gesamtheit also insofern
ein großes plädoyer noch was konkrete
dinge konkret um sowohl der grenze ist
besser beenden als jetzt herrscht rom
mit dem plädoyer für hertha auf vier
jahren
haben sie nach diesen und
seitlich gegen den vollkommen rechnen am
ende würde diese art von politik weniger
kosten dass das geld das wir den taliban
nach geworfen haben das war vor kurzem
eine milliarde euro aber das kann nicht
passieren weil wir nur noch ganzheitlich
verhandeln und handeln wollen wir müssen
auch die flüchtlingskrise europäische
lösen das heißt wenn jetzt flüchtlinge
diese armen leute aus der ukraine müssen
sich jetzt schon portugal und spanien
entscheiden das thema machen wir jetzt
gleich sie machen jetzt wieder ein
großes fass auf das machen wir gleich
nach einer ganz kurzen unterbrechung
sind werden zurück und herr bruder wird
das dann ausführlich bis gleich
[Musik]
falls wir kommen zurück meine damen und
herren und es geht geschwind weiter mit
dem aufreger des tages soll der these
des tages von hartroda
ich war schon dran ja ich habe sie
gerade abgehoben naja gut okay dann
nämlich normalerweise muss man sie auch
gar nicht so sehr bitten oder der sie
sprechen nein da bin ich sehr
pflegeleicht
nein ich wollte eigentlich immer dieser
katastrophe sprechen die sich in zwei
flugstunden von uns entfernt vollzieht
in der ukraine und jetzt bin ich bisher
eingenordet worden mit so wichtigen
sachen wie ohrfeigen für stars ich finde
dass einschließlich meiner eigenen
existenz vollkommen unerträglich wir
erleben einen massenmord in echtzeit wir
erleben barbarei auf allen kanälen etwas
was es früher nicht gab weder beim
untergang der titanic noch bei der
deportation in den deutschen
konzentrationslagern
und jetzt erleben wir dass alles live
und
widerstand dagegen fängt an zu erodieren
ich merke das so an den ersten artikeln
oder überlegungen immer gefragt wird ob
es nicht besser wäre wenn die ukraine
kapitulieren dann wird das blutvergießen
beendet ich krieg inzwischen massenweise
briefe die von leuten putin muss
wirklich in der tat vieler troller hier
haben von leuten das russische vorgehen
vollkommen richtig finden ich weiß nicht
wie man in einem land wie die wii
bundesrat in der bundesrepublik leben
kann das wirklich auf friedlicher
koexistenz basiert und dann emotional
sich mit ihm identifizieren kann und das
tun sehr viele zumindest mehr als ich je
angenommen habe weil ich dieses thema
noch nie gearbeitet habe und das ist ich
sage es noch mal es ist ungeheuerlich
wir kriegen das alles mit wir sehen es
und wir debattieren darüber ob wir einen
atomkrieg riskieren wollen wenn wir den
himmel über der ukraine für die angriffe
der russen sperren meiner es muss noch
etwas geben zwischen atomkrieg und
totale kapitulation und die
verlassenheit
tausenden von toten hinnehmen wie es mir
unheimlich
deswegen unheimlich weil ich mir
vorstellen kann wie sich die
europäischen regierungen und dieser
karnevalsvereins namens nato verhalten
würden wenn die gefahr bisschen weiter
sich in den westen bewegt island ist das
sozusagen das gebot der stunde
hier geschlagen hat und ich kann dann
nur wenn sie gestatten willst einen
churchill zitieren der hat mal den
klugen satz gesagt vieler kluger setzt
aber gerade besonders klug hat gesagt
eine pisa ist jemand der ein krokodil
füttert in der hoffnung es werde in als
letztens fassen und das steht uns bevor
wenn wir heute und den nächsten tagen
und wochen nicht den ukrainern helfen
diesen massenmord zu entkommen
also ich habe nicht den eindruck dass
wir den krieg in der ukraine mit
gelassenheit wahrnehmen ich nehme im
gegenteil sehr viel solidarität war
menschen die auf die straße gehen die
demonstrieren und auch versuchen gerade
in den ukrainischen flüchtlingen die
hier ankommen zu helfen meinte das
politische ende und wir haben ja auch
wir sprechen auch politisch von einer
zeitenwende selbst die spd ist jetzt ja
auf die idee gekommen dass auch eine
bundeswehr finanziert werden muss und
ausgestattet werden muss ordentlich
insofern teile ich ihre ihre analyse in
teilen leider nicht aber ich gebe ihnen
recht das thema des information ist ein
ganz wichtiges thema ist ja auch ein
thema was mich bewegt wenn wir auch
gleich noch hören und sie hatten ja
interessanterweise auch noch in ihrer in
ihrem passus den sie eingereicht haben
zum thema haben sie ja auch noch mal das
thema rechtsradikal ead aufgeworfen nur
ein geschmack
alles klar das finde ich tatsächlich ein
ganz interessantes thema weil es ganz
oft parallelen gibt also das ist so
meine wahrnehmung twitter ich habe mich
mal zum thema impfpflicht geäußert
politisch und hatte dann ganz viel
plötzlich zum thema ukraine krieg unter
diesem
unter diesem beitrag und umgekehrt auch
also offensichtlich ist das ja ein
milieu das darauf anspringt und das
finde ich dass information wir auch
gleich mit ihrem themen server ballon
einer rückfrage auch an sehr bruder wenn
sie sagen sie finde es schlimm wie wir
damit umgehen mit dem krieg was könnte
deutschland denn anders machen oder die
deutsche
lösung vorstellen schon mal ein wort zu
klärungen ich war neulich in einem zug
davon mit flüchtlingen war und ich war
wirklich tief gerührt und überrascht von
der hilfsbereitschaft die sie an jeder
station aufs neue abgespielt hat in
polen und später auch in deutschland
ganz viele junge leute die helfen die
sich der flüchtlinge annahmen sehr
eindrucksvoll das waren einer der
wenigen momente wo ich bei einer gesagt
hätte ich bin stolz ein deutscher zu
sein aber was können wir machen chancen
die sache ist was haben wir nicht
gemacht heute in der welt weil
hervorragender artikel ich habe
vergessen von wem darüber wie frau
lambrecht die irgendwie durch einen
wunderbaren zufall der geschichte in das
amt des verteidigungsministers gekommen
ist vielleicht weil ich das angebot
abgelehnt habe wie frau lambrecht vier
wochen lang eine entscheidung über
lieferung von waffen an die ukraine
verzögert hingehalten hat also wenn sich
das normale gemeine volk wahnsinnig gut
verhält fährt die politik eine hinhalte
kurs und wenn sie olaf scholz bei anne
will vor drei tagen gesehen haben dann
wissen sie wie man fragen nicht
beantwortet ich habe verständnis dafür
er kann vieles nicht auf den tisch legen
und schon gar nicht das was viele
journalisten wissen wollen auf welchen
wegen die waffen in die ukraine kommen
hund ähnlich ist schon die fragen sind
albern aber es gab eine verzögerung in
der politischen klasse würde es
wahrscheinlich parteiübergreifend weil
die ansicht vor hersteller von
politischen und bereut dass die ukraine
in drei tagen überrollt sein wird und
dann löst sich das verhältnis eben auf
dem wege der stärke und das ist bis
jetzt nicht eingetreten und dann herr
palmer hat die politik ein hinhalte kurs
ist dass gerade der kurs wie man die
politik in der ukraine krise beschreiben
sollte
da werden sie jetzt sagen
das wundert sie aber ich mache mir da
keinen mutter ich bin ehrlich gesagt
mit dem gefühl der ohnmacht da jetzt
konfrontiert
und ich stelle fest dass ich von
außenpolitik und leben was da abläuft zu
wenig verstehe
dass ich aber nicht sagen kann was er
richtig oder falsch ist schon weil ich
nicht in der lage bin zu beurteilen was
die reaktion der anderen seite sein wird
und deswegen halte ich mich da zurück
ich kann das wenn ich würde das
vernünftig bald das ist nicht so eine
politische frage ist eine frage der
eigenen konsequenz sie können nicht eine
politik machen die auf dem nie wieder
basiert und das nie wieder mein die
gräueltaten der nazis aber nicht
gegrillt hatten die jetzt im namen von
putin und leider eines großen teils der
russischen bevölkerung bekommen werden
das es keine politik da geht es um
praktizierter gelebte angewandte
menschlichkeit und daran mangelt es ich
denke was man schon feststellen kann ist
dass die ampel regierung sehr zögerlich
gehandelt hat insbesondere wenn man es
vergleicht mit anderen anderen ländern
wie beispielsweise großbritannien war
sehr viel schneller beim thema
waffenlieferungen und wir haben uns hier
in deutschland noch für 5000 helme ab
gefeiert und gleichzeitig haben wir ein
bundeskanzler der sagt er war
vorbereitet hat irgendwie ganz viele
schubladen bei sich wo überall
vorbereitungspläne drin sind aber
offenbar war er nicht vorbereitet genug
um auf die situation entsprechend
angemessen zu reagieren
also da frage ich mich schon was stimmt
denn jetzt eigentlich also nicht nur wo
ist scholz sondern was will scholz und
wer ist schuld man muss ihm zugutehalten
dass man in solchen situationen niemand
gerechnet hat und das ist hier ja gesagt
ja aber vielleicht hatte den schlüssel
zum schreibtisch im boliden lassen
konnte nicht mit der er ist ich finde es
auch sehr seltsam dass alle von dem
abzug der amerikaner aus afghanistan
dermaßen überrascht waren wir haben dort
wir haben dort geheimdienst mitarbeiter
werden dort stiftungen vertretungen und
niemand war mit den verhältnissen
vertrauten dasselbe jetzt seit 16 jahren
die ganze regierungszeit von frau merkel
fahren wir ein schmusekurs gegenüber
russland nicht nur auch die nur dem iran
und dann sind wir ganz überrascht dass
eine diktatur sich wie einer diktatur
gelebt was wäre eine überraschung wie
schnee in den sommerferien und das das
erleben wir jetzt in eine eindeutigkeit
die ich gerne vermieden hätte und das
ist wahrscheinlich keine
parteipolitische frage und noch mal ich
verstehe schon dass scholz nicht alles
sagen kann auch nicht alles sagen will
aber jeder tag der verzögerung ist ein
tag der viele menschen das leben kostet
und ich denke ich denke man könnte auch
mit einem russen ein geschäft machen was
sie wissen wahrscheinlich auch es gibt
eine zusammenarbeit zwischen israel und
den russen über die über die aktionen
über dem syrischen oder unter dem
syrischen himmel ist er fliegt dann ganz
unverschämt ganz oft einsätze und
schaltet gewisse gefahrenquellen aus und
die russen wissen das weil sich israel
mit russland abspricht vernünftigerweise
möchte keiner ein flugzeug des anderen
erwischen wieso ist das in der ukraine
nicht möglich kann die nato nicht paar
diskrete fühler ausstrecken und sagen
den russen sagen ihr fliegt da jetzt
nicht drüber aber ihr könnt es eine
tolle propaganda machen wir euch gehen
uns gestellt hat wir wissen es nicht
aber das müsste doch gehen vor allem das
primat müsste sein die rettung von
menschenleben und das ist es nicht es
ist ein sehr sehr gutes schlusswort für
ihr plädoyer das muss es sein menschen
zu retten und sie frau klein sie haben
es ja auch heute ihr thema mitgebracht
was auch was mit putin zu tun hat aber
vor allem mit den ganzen eben schon
angesprochen desinformation
desinformation ganz genau also ich war
vor ein paar tagen in einer
diskussionsveranstaltung mit
schülerinnen und schülern meines
wahlkreises und ein schüler stellte mir
die frage was ich eigentlich davon halte
dass ukrainische flüchtlinge
russischsprachige menschen in
deutschland angreifen und die frage hat
mich sehr verwundert weil ich noch nie
davon gehört habe und auch bis heute
noch nicht davon gehört habe dass
ukrainische flüchtlinge menschen
angreifen bei uns vor allen dingen auch
nicht russischsprachige ich hab dann
recherchiert und festgestellt das ist ja
wohl ein fake video gab in nordrhein
westfalen wo eine frau berichtet auf
russisch von einem 16-jährigen von einem
16 jährigen jugendlichen der von einem
ukrainischen mob totgeprügelt wurde weil
er russisch sprach es hat sich dann
herausgestellt dass dieser vor fallenden
stattgefunden hat die polizei hat auch
direkt dementiert hat auch dazu
aufgefordert dieses fake video nicht zu
teilen und was ich an dem fall ganz
besonders interessant finde ist dass die
frau eigentlich nicht mit böser absicht
gehandelt hat zumindest sieht das so
aber dieses video sich innerhalb
kürzester zeit so stark verbreitet hat
dass es insbesondere auch in den
russischen kanälen sehr stark verbreitet
wurde das ist ein ganz klarer fall von
des informations kampagne wie wir ihn ja
auch schon in der vergangenheit kanten
der fall lisa ist so ein fall und
desinformation hat ihm das ganz klare
ziel menschen zu verunsichern es hat das
ziel das vertrauen in den staat zu
beschädigen und deshalb bin ich der
meinung dass desinformation ein angriff
auf unsere demokratie ist und wir
deshalb unbedingt und dringend den staat
stärken sollten in der wehrhaftigkeit
bei solchen desinformationskampagne
meine these ist putin führt nicht nur
einen krieg mit offen er führt auch ein
informationskrieg und ich habe die große
sorge dass deutschland immer mehr zum
schauplatz auch dieses informations
krieges wird und das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen
herr palmer haben sie vielleicht eine
idee was man dagegen tun kann
so wirklich sehr überzeugend was
verkleiden vorgetragen hat die analyse
bestimmt richtig die antwort was man tun
könnte finde ich erheblich schwieriger
es gibt ja den versuch weil es jetzt
durchsetzungs gesetz im internet
strafbare inhalte zu löschen waren
auffälliger diskussionsprozess ob sich
sowas auch fake news ausweiten liese und
ob man das technisch beherrschen könnte
ist eine frage die ich nicht beantworten
können aber dass man da nicht einfach
wegschauen dachtest würde ich genauso
unterstreicht klaus wie gefährlich ist
dieser des informationskrieg bild wurde
ja zum beispiel als beispiel russland
gesperrt auch wie gefährlich ist es hier
in deutschland die fake news bild hat
für sich eine antwort gefunden immer
alles was wir recherchiert haben und in
deutscher sprache in unserem heimatmarkt
publizieren wird auf russisch übersetzt
und auch sozusagen auf russischer
sprache publiziert ist
ist die erste adresse russisch
sprechende menschen in deutschland da
gibt es ja auch sehr viele putin
verstehe und putin anhänger die auch nur
russische fernsehen gucken also ich
glaube dass das bürgerforum
richtig ist es ist sehr schwer aber es
muss halt jeder dass dagegen tun was er
tun kann medienhäuser können so
reagieren gesetzgeber könne sich genau
angucken was möglich ist und was man
machen kann eltern können ihren kindern
sagen alles was du im netz fließt könnte
falsch sein ob es auch eine zweite
quelle gibt etc lehrer könnten
sachkunde stunden dazu benutzen das wird
dann für den schulen ja auch schon
gemacht im zuge einer medienerziehung
hier ein kritisches bewusstsein zu
schaffen so dass die angreifer
wenigstens nicht auf willfährige
empfänger treffen sondern auf ich sage
jetzt immer ein großes wort gebildet die
das einordnen können das würde schon mal
helfen und ermutigt finde ich auch nicht
zu sagen da geschieht was schreckliches
und man kann kann eigentlich nichts
machen
gesetzgeberisch glaube ich ist es sehr
sehr schwer weil wie in jeder form der
kriminalität der angreifer immer ein
ticken schlauer ist als der verteidiger
der einbrecher immer ein bisschen
schneller wächst als die polizei da das
gilt das sicherlich auch das sind schon
ganz schön raffinierte netzwerke im weg
die das flächendeckend unter die leute
bringen ich glaube nur ein kritischer
grund geist hilft da erst mal als
gegengift ich glaube auch ein anfang
wäre schon gemacht wenn wir uns
überhaupt dieses bewusstsein hätten wenn
wir uns das vor augen führen würden das
ist ein großes problem ist aufklärung
ist auch wichtig wie sie sagen und
gleichzeitig ist sind wir auch da
tatsächlich in einem dilemma weil in
denen wir aufklären über die
falschinformation ich habe ja gerade von
einem fall berichtet poly für ihren wir
die falschen einmal bin ich glaube auch
gar nicht sagen dass ich jetzt die
lösung habe und das rezept für das thema
aber ich glaube wir müssen darüber
sprechen und wir sprechen nicht darüber
wir sollten darüber anfangen zu sprechen
auch wenn wir darüber sprechen wir
werden es nicht los die wenn sie wenn
sie einen heuschnupfen haben können sie
bis fünften tage lang diskutieren da
wird sie nicht
verletzt
ich will nur eins sagen was mich schon
wirklich auch bewegt
wenn
desinformation sozusagen um sich greift
wie sie es beschreiben und ich glaube
sie beschreiben ist richtig dann könnte
ja auch ein weg sein dass man mit der
richtigen information im land des
angreifers zu gange es mir wird bis
heute nicht klar warum es nicht viel
flächendeckend und im westen gelingt die
nachrichtliche deutung des westens ich
sage es mit aller zurückhaltung denn da
ist natürlich auch propaganda drin na ja
nicht alles was die ukraine tolles
machen war vielleicht so toll und alles
was ihnen weg geschieht aus uns über das
sich selber berichten hat vielleicht
wirklich so stattgefunden aber warum wir
nicht in der lage sind den russen die
dafür empfänglich sind sie haben vorhin
eine mehrheit der russen als extrem
putin träumt beschrieben da stimme ich
ihnen zu die haben nämlich gewählt die
mit 55 prozent
so ist es aber das sind ja dann auch
noch ein paar andere und die müssen wir
doch alle medienunternehmen
politik erreichen können früher hätte
man aus flugzeugen flugblätter
abgeworfen ist klar dass das heute aus
verschiedenen gründen möglicherweise
nicht die richtige
maßnahme ist aber was ist eigentlich die
digitale informations kampagne die wir
mit voller power von
den meisten leuten von facebook und
google dass die sagen ja wir sind da
abgeschaltet wir haben längst ein bild
gefunden der information wir dürfen auch
unsere offensive nicht vergessen für die
wichtigen nachrichten
anstatt immer nur zu sagen um die
falschen nachrichten die desinformation
unterwandert sozusagen unser wissen das
finde ich extrem extrem wichtig und es
macht mich auch traurig wir sagen immer
die bösen anderen stadt dass wir uns
wege überlegen wie wir guten ich sage
dass ein bisschen sogar analysiert weil
vielleicht sind wir auch nicht immer so
gut wie wir denken aber um beim beispiel
zu bleiben anstatt zu sagen wie wir
guten zum zug kommen können will man ist
mein lieblingsbeispiel war immer wie
kann nur der amerikanische geheimdienst
das handy von frau merkel hacken das
macht man doch nicht unter freunden
meine frage war wie kann es eigentlich
sein dass die deutsche bundeskanzlerin
ein handy hat das fremde mächte hätten
können ja warum kann nicht sieben sich
hat und einfach
angekommen sie hat einfach nichts zu
verbergen habe ja unsere sendung ist
jetzt zu ende ich möchte mich ganz
herzlich bei meinen gästen bedanken das
war sehr leidenschaftlich heute und sehr
lebendig und wenn sie mögen scheinen sie
doch morgen abend wieder ein um 20.15
hierbei bild wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen schönen abend mit vielen
lebendigen diskussion tschüss
[Musik]